in this video we're going to find the
equation of a tangent line to a graph
through a given point and we're going to
use the power rule so sometimes near the
end of precalculus you learn the
difference quotient as a way of finding
the derivative but here we're going to
use the shortcut that's learned in
calculus called the power rule and the
way this works is you take this exponent
and you bring it down in front of the
variable here x and you subtract 1 then
from the exponent so a simple example
would be like say you had
7x to the fifth you would bring that 5
down 5 times 7 is 35 and then you
subtract 1 from the exponents that'd be
four so that's your derivative and
remember what is the derivative the
derivative is really a formula for
finding the slope of the tangent line
and what we're going to do is we're
going to use the x coordinate to plug in
for X to then find the slope at that
point so let's dive into example number
one and what we're looking at here is
this Parabola 3x squared and what we're
going to do is we're going to find the
equation of the tangent line through
this point one comma 3. so first things
first let's go ahead and
find the derivative and so we're going
to bring down that 2 2 times 3 is 6.
we're going to subtract 1 from the
exponent so that's 6X to the first this
is a formula for the slope of the
tangent line and then if I put 1 in for
X here so this is f Prime of 1 that's
going to be 6 times 1 which is equal to
6. so that means that at this point it's
going to have a slope of 6 the tangent
line
we're going to use our point-slope form
of the equation of a line you probably
remember this from algebra 1. we're
going to say y minus the y coordinate of
the point equals the slope which in this
case is 6 times x minus the x coordinate
of the point let's go ahead and take it
a little further by Distributing so this
is 6X minus 6 and then we'll just get
the Y by itself by adding 3 to both
sides of the equation so we get y equals
6X minus 3. so that's the equation of
our tangent line and let's go ahead and
graph it here so the Y intercept is
negative 3
the slope is 6 which is like six over
one so rise 6 run 1. so you can see that
this graph of our tangent line is going
to look something like
this approximately so you can see it
just barely touches the curve at that
one point at one comma three let's take
a look at another example okay see if
you can do example number two on your
own for practice we've got this function
Negative X cubed plus one which is
graphed right here and we want to find
the equation of the tangent line through
this point negative one comma two so how
would you do that one well if I was
going to do it the first thing that I
would do is I would take the derivative
of this original function and the way we
do that is we bring down the exponent so
3 times negative one this is understood
to be a negative one that's going to
give us negative three we subtract 1
from the power there so that becomes a 2
and the derivative of a constant like
just a number by itself the derivative
of a constant is zero so that just
cancels out
so now we have our derivative which is a
formula for the slope of our tangent
line at any point along this curve but
we're interested in this point negative
one two so what we're going to do is
we're going to put this negative 1 in
place of X so we're going to calculate F
Prime of negative one
negative 1 squared is 1 times negative 3
is negative three so that tells us that
the slope is going to be negative 3
at that point so using our point-slope
form we're going to say y minus our y
coordinate of our Point equals our slope
which is negative 3 times x minus our x
coordinate of our point of course when
you subtract it's like adding the
opposite we're just going to take this a
step further by Distributing so this
comes out to negative 3x minus 3 and
then we're going to get y by itself by
adding 2 to both sides of our equation
so now it's in slope intercept form y
equals negative 3x minus 1 is the
equation of our tangent line let's go
ahead and graph this it has a y
intercept of negative 1. has a slope of
negative 3 which is like negative 3 over
1 so Rise 3 run negative 1. so you can
see that this is going to look something
like this approximately so that if we
graph our tangent line it's just going
to barely touch the graph at that point
there and it has a slope of negative 3
and you got it so great job if this was
helpful I'll go ahead and put another
video that I did talking about the power
rule right over there go ahead and
follow me over to that video if you're
interested in learning more about the
power rule